a lockdown has just been lifted over at  Clark High School metro police reported  gunfire near campus this morning that  led to the lockdown no reports though of  any injuries although we understand the  shooting was reported across the street  from Clark High School parents at the  school described what they heard  there's always a lot of violence here I  don't even know how my kids are getting  good grades because with the  interference of violence here I don't  know how there's kids doing magnet here  again the lockdown has been lifted  students now back allowed back on campus  to and from no other details available  right now it is an ongoing investigation  we'll have more on later newscasts